a dean's letter
from god
in the book of job
chapter 1
reading from verse six
job chapter one
the bible says now there was a day when
the sons of god came to present
themselves before the lord
and satan came also among them
and the lord said unto satan whence
cometh thou
then satan answered and said unto the
lord
from going to and fro in the earth and
from walking up and down in it
and the lord said unto satan
hast thou considered my servant
job
that there is none like him in the earth
and i pause
there is none
like him
in the earth
hast thou considered my school loma
linda
there is none like it in the earth
has thou considered the seventh-day
adventist church
there is none
like it in the earth
has thou considered
esther susan paul john james there is
none like him and there is none like her
in the earth this is a testimony from
god
this is not job describing himself
when we describe ourselves we tend to be
gloriously inaccurate
but not god
when i was at that medical institution
counseling
students would come to me
could you help me write this letter that
letter
could you read offer this
working copy of the dean's letter
i don't know how it functions here but
where i was the dean and the student
would write the letter together and the
students would make changes take it back
to the dean and they would go back and
forth and negotiate a sparkling
recommendation to some
residency program somewhere
and what all students want
is for the dean to say
there is none like him in the history of
medical education
there's none like her in the history of
this institution we
prize this student we send him our forth
with all our best wishes
that's what you want
and if your interest is
ophthalmology
you want the chairman of that department
to write that letter for you
because you know what that letter means
by way of influence and questions not
even asked
and god sent a dean's letter
about job
and he read it himself to satan
hast thou considered my servant job that
there is none like him in the earth a
perfect
upright man
one that feareth god and escheweth evil
he is perfect
he's upright he fears me and he s choose
or he avoids evil
then satan answered the lord and said
doth not doth job serve god for not
do you believe that job serves you for
nothing
has not thou made a hedge about him
and about his house and about all that
he hath on every side
thou has blessed the work of his hands
and his substance is increased in the
land but put forth thy hand now and
touch all that he hath and he will curse
thee to thy face
the devil knows he knew then
and he knows even more now
that the things we have
mean so much to us
they create serious competition
with god
at this point
an amen would be quite timely
thank you very much
let me say it again for those of you who
didn't like it
the devil knows
that our material possessions
our academic distinctions all that we
have acquired that make us in a secular
context someone important he knows that
these things create a tremendous
barrier between us and a total surrender
to the sovereignty of christ in our
lives he knows that and so he told god
job serves you
because of what he has because of what
you've given him you had to buy him
but put forth thy hand now
and touch all that he hath and he will
kiss thee
to thy face
and the lord said unto satan behold all
that he hath is in thy power
only on himself put not forth thy hand
and satan went forth from the presence
of the lord and we know the story
he lost his oxen and his asses
he lost his sheep
lost his camels
lost all ten children
in one day
you may fail an exam or quiz and you're
ready to jump off a building
job lost
all
children
in one day
lost all his material possessions in one
day
one after the other the bad news came
you've lost your oxes and your oxen and
your asses you've lost your sheep you've
lost your camels you've lost all your
children and job collapsed
the lord giveth he said
the lord taketh away
blessed be the name
of the lord now chapter two of the book
of job reading from verse one
again there came a day when the sons of
god came to present themselves before
the lord and satan came also among them
to present himself before the lord and
the lord said unto satan
whence cometh thou
and said and answered the lord and said
from going to and from the earth
and from walking up and down in it and
the lord said unto satan hast thou
considered my servant job you see
sometimes god has to say something twice
when joseph was called to interpret
pharaoh's dream
joseph told pharaoh the reason why he
got the dream twice is because it was
confirmed and established by god so if
you're praying for something ask god to
answer you again
ask god to confirm it he's in the habit
of confirming
god said to satan has thou considered my
servant job that there's none like him
in the earth a perfect and upright man
one that feareth god and a street evil
and still he hold this fast his
integrity although thou movest me
against him to destroy him
what are the final words of that verse
without
a cause
still he hold this fast
his integrity
he has lost his ox nice asses he still
holds onto god he has lost his camels he
holds on to god he has lost his sheep he
holds on to god he has lost most of his
servants he holds on to god he has lost
his ten children he holds on to god he's
about to lose his wife he holds onto god
what if you lose your job this coming
monday
what if i lost
my power of sight on my gift of speech
could i still hold on to god for dear
life
and god said still he hold this fast his
integrity although thou movest me
against him to destroy him without a
cause now let me pause on without a
cause
god does not act rashly
and purposelessly
if god
lays some punishment upon you
he has
a cause
come on say amen
if god removes something from your life
he has a cause he does not act
causelessly there is a verse in the
bible that says the curse causeless
shall not come
it is god who invented the great law of
cause and effect
and while he may not be bound by the law
he follows it
in the sense that he operates on cause
and effect
god told satan you're trying to get me
to destroy job even though i have no
cause to destroy him if god had a cause
he would have destroyed him
question number one
as you and i worship in this building
[Music]
does god have just cause to bless us
or to destroy us
don't look around
look at yourself
as you sit where you sit
just reflect on your life now reflect on
mind for the past 24 hours
have we given god cause to bless us
or destroy us
either way
he functions on the basis of a cause
and he told the devil
you are inciting me that's what moves me
against him to destroy him
without
a cause
why was it god had no cause to destroy
job
hast thou considered my servant job
there is none
like him
in the earth
now that can be said of a person's one
of two reasons the degree of your
wickedness or the height of your
christ's likeness
in the case of job it was the presence
of god in job and then god elaborates on
the details a perfect
and an upright man one that feareth god
and estu with evil
when this is the quality of your life
god has no cause
to destroy you
i'll ask you again no question no no
response needed
can god describe you
as perfect meaning mature
can you describe me as
upright
do i
fear god
do you
eschew evil meaning do you avoid the
possibility of coming not avoid doing it
avoid the very possibility of coming
into contact with it
when this is your life and this is mine
god has cause
to show off
to all those who inhabit the heavens and
that's what he was doing to satan
showing off and the only being in all
the universe with any justification for
showing off is god
and where god likes to show us our show
off is the center stage of our lives
but we must not occupy it at the same
time
when actors do their thing on the stage
the audience applauds and then they come
back from the wings and they bow and
they do whatever they bow yes god wants
to be on that stage alone
our lives are stages we offer to god
that god may show the world the kind of
god he is our lives are not stages for
the performance of who we think we are
and job's life was a stage on which god
performed before the devil and then god
had an act too
he could not
destroy job
he had no cause because job was a
righteous man
let me give the heart of the message in
this sentence
where there is righteousness
there can be no destruction
quarter to twelve
program i was told is running a little
late so that makes me smile
because i can say it was not my fault
so i will take the time i need all those
who love the word say amen
amen let us go to the book
of genesis
we'll read from verse 4 as we continue a
dean's letter from god genesis chapter
4.
and for those of you who here for the
first time for public reading i use the
king james so you'll
know why what i say differs from what
you read if you have some other version
genesis chapter 4 reading from verse 1
and adam knew eve his wife and she
conceived and bear cain and said i have
gotten a man from the lord
and she again bear his brother abel
and abel was a keeper of sheep but cain
was the tailor of the ground and in
process of time it came to pass that
cain brought of the fruit of the ground
an offering unto the lord unable he also
brought of the firstlings of his flock
and of the fat thereof and the lord had
respect unto abel and to his offering
but unto cain and to his offering he had
not respect and cain was very roth and
his countenance fell and the lord said
unto cain why are thou wroth and why is
thy countenance fallen if
if thou do as well condition
shalt thou not be accepted and if thou
doest not well sin lieth at the door and
unto thee shall be his desire and thou
shall rule over him
and cain talked with abel his brother
and it came to pass when they were in
the field that cain rose up against abel
his brother and slew him we have the
first murder
a brother
against the brother
as a result
of a conflict over worship
cain brought the fruit of the ground
able brought of the first links of his
flock and of the fat thereof
and we're told and the lord had respect
unto abel
and to his offering god is very specific
he respects the man
and respects the man's gift
he is equally disrespectful to cain but
unto cain and to his offering he had no
respect
now why did god accept abel
and his gift
and reject so thoroughly cain
here's why it's important to study here
a little very little precept upon
precept let's run all the way to the
book of hebrews chapter 11 we shall read
verse 4. hebrews 11 verse 4 as we
continue a dean's letter from god
hebrews 11
reading from verse 4.
by faith
abel offered unto god a more excellent
sacrifice than cain by which he obtained
witness that he was what
righteous
obtained witness from whom
god
now if god says you're all right don't
worry about what other people say
we're very concerned about what other
people say and to some degree because
human beings must interact with others
we ought to have some concern but it
must not be the overriding concern
by which he obtained witness he was
righteous god testifying of his gifts
and by it he being dead yet speaketh god
was a witness to the righteousness of
abel
and when there is righteousness there is
acceptance
which tells me on the other side of that
coin
there was nothing righteous about cain
nor his sacrifice
let's learn a little more about abel
let's go to first john chapter three
first john three reading from verse 10
as we continue a dean's letter from god
a recommendation from god a character
reference from god first john 3
reading verse 10
11 and 12.
the bible says in this the children of
god are manifest
and the children of the devil
whosoever dweth not righteousness is not
of god neither he that loveth not his
brother verse 11 for this is the message
that he heard from the beginning that we
should love one another not as cain who
was of that wicked one and slew his
brother and wherefore slew he him
because his own works were wicked and
his brothers what righteous
the bible is difficult and easy at the
same time
but i believe it's more easy than
difficult
the answer to the conflict between cain
and abel is very clear
what abel did was right
what kane did was wrong
when you do what's right
you generate opposition from those doing
what's wrong
if you go to some professional meeting
everyone's smoking like chimneys
drinking like fish
and you are
respecting the sixth commandment thou
shalt not kill by not injuring your body
someone may think well who do you think
you are
i don't think i'm anything
i just don't drink
i just don't smoke
because that's one way i worship my god
who dwells in this temple
perhaps in high school
you didn't do what the other children
did and they resented you
not because you stole their lunch money
but simply because you chose to live
your life along principles of
righteousness i am saying that
righteousness wherever it exists it
excites murderous homicidal opposition
and for fear of that
some people choose to go along with the
crowd because when you go to the crowd
no one resents you
you're just fine that's why jesus said
if he were of the world the world would
love his own
and since we fundamentally love
acceptance
we go where we get it quickest
and at the least cost
but acceptance with christ means the
sacrifice of all that you have
let's learn some more about abel as we
continue with dean's letter from god
matthew chapter 23
reading from verse 29
matthew 23 reading from verse 29.
the bible says warn to you scribes and
pharisees hypocrites
for you build the tomb of the prophets
and garnish the sepulchre of the
righteous and say if we have been in the
days of our fathers we would not have
been partakers with them in the blood of
the prophets
what they're saying to jesus is look our
forefathers kill the prophets but if we
had been alive then we would not have
killed them jesus says be witnesses unto
yourselves that ye are the children of
them that kill the prophets in other
words you have the same mindset so you
are just of guilty even though you have
not physically done it
that's a very very serious principle
the bible teaches
all you have to have
is the same attitude
and you're just as guilty
because if your attitude
could be mingled with the opportunity
the action would follow
now that's a standard of righteousness
that exists only in heaven and is
required of those on earth on earth who
claim jesus christ as having transformed
our lives not even by attitude we offend
god
so you're not a racist by behavior
are you sympathetic to those who are
then you are no different in god's eyes
you don't believe in
genocide
but you don't mind if certain group of
people are wiped off the face of the
earth
even though you won't do it yourself
or i won't do it then i am just as
guilty
and so in verse 34 jesus says to them
wherefore behold i send unto you
prophets
wise men and scribes
some of whom you shall kill and crucify
some of them shall ye scourge in your
synagogue and persecute from city to
city now listen to verse 35 that upon
you may come all the righteous blood
righteous blood shed upon the face of
the earth from the blood of whom
righteous abel which means abel was
either a prophet a wise man or a scribe
jesus describes abel as righteous
in hebrews paul describes him as
righteous
in first john he's described as
that's why god accepted him and his
sacrifice
righteousness is the key
let's go to
genesis chapter six
five minutes to twelve
genesis six
reading from verse five
if someone next to you is sleeping
bump the person
accidentally
and try to wake the person up these are
words of life not because they're my
words but because they come from the
word of god and god's word jesus said in
john 6 63 the words that i speak unto
you they are spirit and they are what
life
what text did i say
genesis what verse
i'll come to 16
and god saw that the wickedness of man
was great in the earth
and that every imagination of the
thoughts of his heart was only evil
continually
and it repented the law that he had made
man on the earth and it grieved him at
his heart
the lord said
i will destroy man whom i have created
from the face of the earth both man and
beast in the creeping thing in the files
of the air for it repentantly that i
have made them verse it says but
noah
found grace
in the eyes of the lord why
verse 9 these are the generations of
noah noah was a just man and perfect in
his generations and noah walked with god
now let's get another word that sums up
all of that perfect justin walking with
god genesis 7 verse 1
as we continue with dean's letter from
god a reference from god a
recommendation from god genesis 7 1 and
the lord said unto noah come thou and
all thy house into the ark for thee have
i seen what
come on say it
righteous
before me
not before the eyes of people
in this generation
noah
is described by god
as a righteous man
and because he was righteous he could
not be a part of the destruction that
god threatened in verse 7 i will destroy
man whom i have created he did not
include noah because noah did not give
him a cause as god told satan
god has no cause to destroy a righteous
man or a righteous woman righteousness
is protection from the wrath of god
whether by fire or by flood
question again don't answer me
as you sit where you sit and i stand
where i stand
are you righteous don't answer me
are you righteous
does god have calls to destroy you or me
but noah found grace in the eyes of the
lord because according to god's own
well-worthy testimony noah was a
righteous man that's the only thing that
qualified him to get into that ark
not how much money he had
and he had a lot of money says in the
book patriarchs and prophets
page 95 i think it is noah invested all
his possessions into the ark
i am speaking here until the 5th of
march do i have to always beg you for
amen at the right times
noah
invested
all his possessions
like paul
but what things were given to me those i
counted loss for christ until you and i
take everything that makes us who we are
and we dump it
which means we have nothing then we say
to jesus christ make me something
through you
there is no raw material you can bring
to god with which to say god use this to
make something out of me
let's see what else the bible has to say
about noah
second peter chapter two
reading verse five
this is brother noah
second peter chapter two reading verse
five we continue with dean's letter from
god or recommendation from god or a
reference
from god it's one minute to 12.
ii peter chapter 2 verse 5 and spared
not the old world
but save noah the earth first the if
person a preacher of what
righteousness now in genesis go to
genesis 7 1 and keep second peter 2 5.
i want you flip back and forth you've
got 10 fingers put one on the second
peter 2 5 1 on genesis 7 1. and i want
to show you a vital principle
do we have both verses
listen to genesis 7 1
and the lord said unto noah come thou on
all thy house into the ark for thee have
i seen righteous meaning god tells noah
you are righteous you yourself
that means the walk
are you with me
now let's go to second peter 2 5
and spared not the old world but save
noah the 8th person a preacher of
righteousness that's the talk
what am i about to say we ought to
walk the walk and
god bless you sister
noah
talk the talk
and walk the walk
and both testimonies came not from him
but from divine sources
in genesis 7 1 god said you're righteous
ii peter 2 5 the holy ghost tells peter
the right he's a preacher of
righteousness what he does is righteous
what he says is righteous that
combination should describe you and me
so many adventists we are past masters
at talking the talk
but not even god can get us to walk the
walk
i have sometimes wondered
what would some of the pioneers say and
if you're not a seventh-day adventist
when we say pioneers we mean those who
built the foundations of this church
somebody say amen
i've always wondered what they would say
if god would raise them up as jesus
raised up some dead saints when he came
from the grave to see
they may say lord
put us back into the grave
please
this is not what we had in mind
this is not why we suffered and
sacrificed and that being seven days a
week
this is not a reason
i've wondered if the lord would raise up
james white who started our publishing
work
and let him read some of our periodicals
and see what's in them
what would that godly man do and say
my brothers and my sisters listen to me
not because it's me but i'm speaking
from god's word
you can talk the talk
with the voice and the language and the
tongue of angels you know paul said i
speak with the tongues of men and of
angels you can talk it with the tongue
of angels
and if you don't walk it
we are sounding brass
on expensive symbols
making costly noise
and having no lasting effect with
respect to people's eternal salvation
noah walked the walk
he talked the talk he could not be
destroyed in that flood because he was
righteous and your my question to you
and to me are we righteous
let's take another look where
righteousness is a protection from
destruction
genesis 18 the story of god and two
angels coming down to inform abraham
that god was about to bring fiery end to
sodom gomorrah admiral zaboy mandela
the cities of the plain
he meets at the tent of abraham he
enjoys a meal
verse 22 the bible says and the men rose
up turned their faces from thence and
went towards sodom referring to the two
angels they went ahead to sodom and
gomorrah
but abraham stood yet before the lord
verse 23 of genesis 18 the bible says
and abraham drew near and said
will thou also destroy the righteous
with the wicked
there are only two classes of people on
this earth
the righteous
and the wicked i don't care how many
groups sociology classifies society in
the upper middle class elite super elite
ultra elite lower middle class even
lower than that under the grave i don't
care
the bible says there are two classes of
people and it is not based on what you
have it's based on who you are in jesus
or who you're not
righteous and wicked which one are you
all righteous people say amen
i should have said i'll save people then
you'd be more comfortable saying amen
there isn't a third class
will thou also destroy the righteous
with the wicked
for adventure there be fifty righteous
within the city
will thou also destroy and not spare the
place for the fifty righteous that are
therein abraham understands where there
is righteousness there cannot be
destruction
without knowing the greek and the hebrew
word for righteousness
we know it's a protection from god's
wrath
that be far from thee verse 25 to do
after this manner to slay the righteous
with the wicked and that the righteous
should be as the wicked that be far from
thee sometimes we say that's the
furthest thing from my mind and god
agrees destroying a righteous person is
the furthest thing from my mind can you
say amen
god has no plan no desire no intention
nor scheme to destroy righteous people
and abraham correctly says that before
from thee
to destroy the righteous with the wicked
and that the righteous should be as the
wicked that be far from thee shall not
the judge of all the earth do right what
does it mean by right the right thing to
do is to destroy the wicked and to save
the righteous that's right says abraham
and god agrees
are we righteous
god agrees
when you can challenge god like that
shall not the judge of all the earth do
right
and the person abraham was talking to
was jesus christ the same one who came
and died
the same one whose righteousness we need
he's the same one who does the
destroying
and he can recognize his own
righteousness in his people
verse 26 genesis 18
and the lord said if i find in sodom 50
righteous people
and i will spare all the place
for their sakes
do you see how powerful righteousness is
mr cameraman can i just
you know when you fly long distances los
angeles melbourne australia you're told
get up and walk
so i'm just walking a little
to aid the circulation
god said if i find in sodom
50 righteous people 10 of these
i will spare how much of the place
all the place why
for their sakes
which means
that righteousness
saves the righteous
and where righteousness is found it
provides a suspension of judgment for
the wicked
now i did not say a cancellation of
judgment
a suspension
give the wicked some more time why
because the righteous are so close to
you
now god didn't say if i find 50
righteous i'll save the 50 righteous and
destroy the rest he said if i find 50
righteous i will spare all the place for
their sake that's how powerful
righteousness is and so you can
understand why god is so eager that his
people be righteous because our
righteousness is a blessing to others
verse 27 genesis 18
and abraham answered and said behold now
i have taken upon me to speak unto the
lord which amber a dust and ashes poor
adventure they shall act five of the
fifty will thou destroy all the city for
lack of five
abraham says lord what's the difference
between 50 and 45
you know when i go to the stores and i
see something costs 39.95
and i've always been bothered by that
why not just put forty dollars
there must be a psychological it's
always 95 or 99 or 98 it is never a
wrong figure
abraham argues for wrong figures
lord what's the death as people say
between 50
and 45
and god is so gracious
do you hear me
he is so gracious he said
if i find there
40 and 5
no i won't do it
yes i won't do it
and he's speaking to him yet again and
said
per adventure
there be 40.
god said i will not do it
for forty sake
then in verse 30
oh let not the lord be angry and i will
speak
for adventure there shall thirty be
found there and he said
i will not do it if i find thirty there
that's how powerful right even a little
righteousness can save a city
abraham took him down to 20
then to
10. and god said
i will not destroy it
for 10 sake one fifth the original
amount
god couldn't find ten
he found one
a lot
now you say we're lot's daughters well
we don't know if lost daughters were
righteous but god brought them out
because a lot
you know the bible describes lot as
righteous
let me show you the degree to which god
respects righteousness
10 after 12.
genesis 18 reading from verse 15
as we continue a dean's letter from god
a recommendation from god character
reference from god and that reference
has to be righteousness every word of
that recommendation
and when the morning came
then the angels hasten lord saying arise
take thy wife and i two daughters which
are here lest thou be consumed in the
iniquity of the city and while he
lingered the man laid hold upon his hand
and upon the hand of his wife and upon
the hand of his two daughters the lord
being merciful unto him and they brought
him forth and set him without the city
he lingered
it's not thought it's not that what
verse 16 says and while he was lingering
and maybe malingering
the angels grabbed him
that tells me two things
how highly god values righteousness
and the consequence of that how eager he
is to save and how unwilling he is to
destroy the angels literally physically
laid hold on lot and his wife and his
two daughters and pulled them out of the
city
and then people say god is mean
god uses human beings as fuel for the
fires of hell
ezekiel 33 verse 11 as i live save the
lord almost and off he swears i take no
pleasure in the death of the wicked
verse 17 genesis 18
and it came to pass when he had brought
them forth abroad
and he said unto him
escape for thy life
look not behind thee neither stay thou
in all the planes escape to the
mountains lest thou be consumed
now
if the angel had told me that
i would have said
no problem
i am gone
i would have been gone while he was
talking
verse 18 genesis 18
and lord said unto them oh not so my
lord
no no no no angel let's discuss this
business of getting away out of let's
discuss
let me introduce my perspective
on your plan for my salvation
verse 19 behold now thy servant hath
found grace in thy sight and thou have
magnified thy mercy which thou hast
showed unto me in saving my life
and i cannot escape to the mountain lest
some evil take me and i die evil there
doesn't mean sin it means some
unfortunate accident like a lion and a
snake biting him or something
verse 20 behold now this city is
natively unto and it is a little one oh
let me escape slither it is not a little
one and my soul shall live
so lord tells the angel
you are sending me to the mountain i
prefer to go to that little city called
zor
imagine that you imagine the two angels
lot
and his two daughters the wife is now
salt the two angels lot and his two
daughters
the angels say come on come on go to
that mountain
san bernardino mountains lot said no no
no no
no no you see that little city over
there that's where we want to go
but lot was a righteous man
i never said lord was a flawless man
verse 21
amazing
and he said unto him
see
in other words i want you to understand
the extent to which i'm going to save
your skin
the angel says see
i have accepted thee concerning this
also that i will not overthrow this city
for the which thou hast spoken
now the angels had told lot that they
had come down to destroy the cities of
the plains
then the angel said because
you have spoken for that city
i will not destroy it
verse 22
hasty
escape scissor for i cannot do
anything until thou become fitter in
other words lot until you go to that
city you ask me permission to go in to
go until you move i can't do anything
here because i cannot hurt you
why
let's find out why second peter chapter
two
reading verse seven and eight
as we continue with dean's letter from
god
character reference from god
second peter chapter two verse seven
in verse four
god destroys the angels he sends them
down to hell that's that rebelled
against him verse five he spares noah
brings the flood on the old world verse
six turning the cities of sodom and
gomorrah into ashes condemned them with
an overthrow verse seven and delivered
just lot
vexed with the filthy conversation of
the wicked verse 8 for that what kind of
man
righteous man
dwelling among them in seeing and
hearing vexed his righteous soul from
day to day with their unlawful deeds lot
was so righteous that his life was a
life of pain because of what he saw he
was disturbed every day
question number three four five i forget
which one don't answer me
does sin
disturb you
the sin upset me
when you look around whether it's your
city your state your country your church
your school and you see things not going
god's way are you disturbed
no i'm very very serious
there's no such thing as a casual walk
with god with no interest in what's
going on around us because we're the
salt of the earth
the bible says one of the reasons lord
was righteous his soul was vexed from
day to day why because of all the sin
around him sin must break our hearts
ezekiel 9 4 when ezekiel sees a
destroying angel coming on jerusalem the
angel says go through the midst of the
city through the midst of jerusalem and
set a mark on all the foreheads of the
men that sigh and cry for all the
abominations that are done in the midst
set a mark upon the men that sigh and
cry those whose hearts break because of
sin
and so lot was spared
he was righteous
and so in genesis 19 you read it when
you get home
verse 18 to 23.
lot discussing with the angel
an alternative to the mountains
eventually lot went to the mountains
because we find out sooner or later
god's way is the best come on say
something eventually lock went to the
mountain
righteousness abel was righteous
god accepted him
noah was righteous
abraham was righteous god accepted him
lot was righteous god could not destroy
him
job was righteous
god had no cause to destroy him
the key
is
righteousness
righteousness isn't something god sends
you
whether by fedex dhl facts or whatever
other means of
quick transportation or conveyance
righteousness is something god brings
righteousness is something god
brings
you know i think this side loves the
word more than this side
i don't know why but righteousness is
something god brings
nothing beats a failure but a trial let
me try
righteousness is something god brings
[Applause]
now we're on equal footing god bless you
what do i mean righteousness is
something god brings because if you
don't have christ you don't have
righteousness
philippians chapter three
reading from verse four
let's read from verse 5 paul is giving
the list of all his secular
accomplishments 20 minutes after 12.
paul says
circumcise the eighth day
of the tribe of israel of the of the
stalk of israel of the tribe of benjamin
a hebrew of the hebrews as touching the
law of pharisee concerning zeal
persecuting the church touching the
righteousness of the law blameless
those are my credentials
seven of them
almost suggesting the completeness of
earthly honor
nothing else paul could have wanted
everything
the next verse says but what things were
gained to me those i counted loss for
christ
what are you and i willing to count as
loss
for jesus christ
can you give up that unsaved boyfriend
that unsafe girlfriend
with no noticeable measurable interest
in salvation
can you give up that friendship that
tends to draw you from jesus and not to
him
can you give up that membership in that
golf country club where people always
bashing
god and government
can you give up
spending three hours between two and six
in the morning on the computer playing
whatever you play
can you give up a few hours of mountain
climbing and dedicate them to bible
study climbing zion
but what things were given to me says
paul in other words i am very clear
these were important in my life no
guesswork those were the very things i
count but lost
for the excellency
of the knowledge of christ jesus my lord
for whom have suffered the loss of most
things somebody correct me quick
all things
and do count them but what
done
you're lost but i want you to get the
word dung
you know what dung is
who values them
except you're a gardener
you see dung has usefulness don't
misunderstand me
i am staying at a good man called dr
fred bischoff nice fellow we have
delightful chats
and my roommate is a distinguished
curtis farnham on this
uh what's that thing he's working there
a camera
say a man for curtis
all right
and i was watching dr bischoff before he
went off to some place yesterday
and he was putting what looked like dung
among the flowers
and i said amen for down when it's put
but beyond that it has no use so paul
says i count everything that was secular
to me as dung
why that i may win christ you see here
we have cause and effect
you cannot win christ
when your arms are burdened
with dung
you've got to drop something
to free your hands to hold something
else
that i may win christ and be found in
him not having my own righteousness
which is what he described back in
verses five and six
circumcised the eighth day of the tribe
of israel
of the stock of benjamin a hebrew of the
hebrews as touching the law of pharisee
concerning zeal persecuting the church
touching the righteousness which is in
the law blameless all of that was the
dong which he dropped that he may win
christ
and be found in him not having my own
righteousness which is of the law but
that which is through the faith of
christ the righteousness which is of god
by faith and it is faith in jesus christ
what i am saying to you
wherever god sees righteousness
he sees reason to bless
wherever god sees righteousness he sees
reasons to save and preserve and prosper
because when he sees righteousness he
sees jesus
and that righteousness
in the person of jesus christ
is available to us
this morning or afternoon
if i told you they were selling
mercedes-benz
downtown san bernardino or wherever they
sell them
for three hundred dollars down ten
dollars a month for two months
you would leave the service
you would get up from your medical
school graduation
and you would go
picture ten you know
when god destroys people he'll have a
reason during the rose bowl parade there
are people who camp overnight on the
sidewalk
am i right
yes why to get a good spot
you tell that same person make a
sacrifice for christ and that person
cannot understand
there are people who camp overnight
outside ticket offices to get playoff
tickets for games
christians
you tell them come to prayer meeting for
an hour
and then god is supposed to understand
understand what
paul gave up everything
we read what ellen white said noah gave
up everything and of course the highest
expression of self-giving
jesus christ
gave up
everything
to take on our humanity
now he tells us
give up everything to take on my
righteousness
we will do that if we view christ's
righteousness highly the way paul did
that which was gained to me i counted
loss for christ
the excellency of the knowledge of
christ jesus my lord we have done and we
have excellency and today jesus offers
us the excellency of his righteousness
righteousness
is life
in jesus christ
righteousness is not something jesus
sends it is something he brings through
his holy spirit because ultimately
righteousness is jesus christ himself
that's why we're told the lord our
righteousness
you don't get it and say jesus i've got
it
it is jesus i have you
and his life
becomes our life literally in the sense
that his dependence and his father his
victories become ours
and what i'm saying to you in the waning
moments of this message is that that
righteousness that saved abel that
righteousness that spared noah that
righteousness that delivered lot that
righteousness can be yours and mine
today
now through faith in jesus christ it is
not given on the basis of membership in
the church
it is given
when a person lays everything down
and says to god
father
i come to you
with nothing in my hands
give me the righteousness of jesus
christ
and the glorious thing is god
gives it
you check the bible i've looked i
haven't seen it yet maybe it's there
i've never seen it but i've never seen
angels described as righteous
they described as holy
but i have not yet seen the expression
righteous
angels
because righteousness which jesus
demonstrated when he walked this earth
it is that quality of life that
conformity with god's high standard of
righteousness that is worked out through
faith in god through dependence on him
and this was the righteousness jesus
christ worked out which was perfect with
his father's character and he gives it
to us no angel has walked this earth and
resisted temptation they are holy but
through christ we are righteous
and the righteousness is available to
you now
you know we sometimes say something is
available for the asking
so it is
with the righteousness of christ
because righteousness as i said it is
life
it is the very life of christ
in galatians 3 verse 21 paul says is the
law then against the promises of god god
forbid for if there had been a law which
could have given life verily
righteousness should have been by the
law life and righteousness in that verse
are the same thing
so that a righteous life righteousness
isn't something you wear it is something
you are
and that your greatest joy
is pleasing god in every aspect and
department of the life
righteousness it touches how you dress
it touches how you eat it touches how
you spend your money it touches who
becomes your close friend it touches
your social activities it touches your
recreation it touches your choice of
academic uh
performance it touches everything
god wants to save
you that's why he sent his son
and there's no need for any man or any
woman to leave this place this morning
uncovered
let me repeat there is no need it would
be suicidal for you to leave this
building knowing that the righteousness
of christ his very life brought to you
by himself in the person of the holy
spirit is available to you and to me for
the asking
and we leave this place
trusting in our own strength
and our own accomplishments as paul used
to do
and so i call upon you as your brother
in jesus christ
and as god's appointed manservant
messenger mouthpiece
if there's a man or a woman under the
sound of my voice he will say lord
i want the certainty of being covered
and filled with the righteousness of
jesus christ
i want you to raise your right hand
god bless you keep it up keep it up
unless it causes pain keep it up
god
establishes things by repeating them
abraham abraham samuel samuel saul saul
peter peter martha martha
if you are serious in raising your hand
you confirm it by standing
and you can take the hand down as you
stand
here's why you're standing
father
i want to leave this place
filled within
and covered without with the
righteousness of jesus christ
listen to me
it will change how you think about
everything
it won't make you do worse in school
it won't cause you to be fired from job
necessarily it won't cause you to go
from being a medical student to being an
art student no no no no all that changes
it now you put that into the service of
god
you bring that under his control under
his supervision under his divine
management now he controls and leads
so don't be afraid if you give your life
to christ he puts you out of medical
school i am not
preaching but what he will do
is say to the devil
i have no cause to destroy him
i have no cause to destroy her and if
god has no cause to destroy you then he
has cause to save you because there
isn't a third choice we don't preach
purgatory because it's not here
every head bowed reverently please
every i close equally reverently
father in the name of jesus
i come to you now as your servants
and i ask you forgive me for anything
i've done to offend you while i've been
in this desk
if i've been guilty of self-promotion
self-glorification i pray
for your forgiveness
as i apologize to you
humanity takes over so easily sometimes
when a person does your work if i have
lifted up myself i ask for your
forgiveness i am sorry
please accept my apology
lord you sent jesus to die for those
standing before you
on the floor and up here
and in the name of jesus fathers we come
i ask you to accept us for his sake
now lord i'm about to make a very
serious appeal and i need the help of
your holy spirit even more
to touch hearts
soften hearts
break down pride and expose the softness
of the inner soul
father
give me the right words to make this
appeal i pray
while every head is bowed
and every eye is closed
any man
any woman who will say lord
i have heard this message
and deep down in my heart i cannot say
that i have given up everything and
given my life a hundred percent to
christ i cannot say that but i do it now
that i may receive his righteousness
if there's a man or woman who will save
that giving up everything for christ
i want you to leave your seat
and come right here
come quickly
because you know your heart
i'm not calling everyone
i'm calling those who fit the
description of the call you know in your
heart you have not really given
everything to jesus christ that's the
call
now no one else knows but you and christ
and you're a fool everyone but not god
now you come and say jesus i give myself
to you 100
cover me and fill me with your
righteousness you come
don't look to see who's coming you just
come
when adam and eve sin god came spoke to
adam by himself then spoke to eve by
herself then spoke to the serpent by
himself
that's how god deals with us you know in
your heart
and i know in mind we have not truly
given ourselves 100 there's nothing
extreme about 100
we'll do that now and we'll ask god to
give us the righteousness of jesus
christ
and we believe it
you come
this is no time to be
cool
and reserved
who else will move
not because i call but the spirit
touches your heart who else will move
god bless you sister
god bless you
god sees and records your movement god
bless you sister coming to my left
god bless you over to my right come
don't hesitate come
god bless you my good brother god bless
you sister to the left my sister to the
back god bless you
come my good brother god bless you
sister come
you come down the center aisle god bless
you
coming to give ourselves 100 to christ
at whatever cost it is come my dear two
sisters god bless you
i feel deep in my heart someone else
some others ought to move i'll wait for
you
some others ought to move don't know who
you are don't know your names but the
holy spirit knows you and is touching
your heart you move and come
don't hesitate
god bless you sister
lord bless my good sister come god bless
you my good sister god bless you just
come
don't think come
and i mean i don't think too much just
come you're coming for life you're
coming for jesus christ
anyone else
slip out and come
as the showers of blessing come down
symbolizing god's approval you come who
else will move then i pray
you're coming to say father in all
honesty i have not given myself 100
and i know it
but today that changes now give me the
righteousness of your son
anyone else will move god bless you
sister you come
god bless you here in the front to my
right
who else will come
god bless you sister come
if you're standing by someone whom you
know ought to move take that person's
hand and bring the person you'll be
surprised the person will not fight you
we need to save one another who else
will come
let the reigns come god bless you
god bless you
god bless you i mean that god bless you
god bless you my dear brother god bless
you
from my heart god bless you sister god
bless you someone else
someone else come
come bring her ah what a beautiful sight
take her by the hand bring her god bless
the two of you we must save one another
bring her god bless you god sister
behind them god bless you
the food will wait god bless you my two
sisters god bless you come give
ourselves completely to jesus christ
that's all i'm asking completely
no pretense no games let god give us his
righteousness completely
who else will come god bless you my good
brother
come
god bless you i love you for coming i
want to say that
we know we have not been 100 with god we
know it
let's do the right and decent thing and
come 100
god bless you as you come come
praise the name of the living god come
his holy spirit knows how to move hearts
god bless you my sister god bless you
what a beautiful sight when young people
move
any age moves but particularly the young
god has so many of your lives so much to
use for his glory come
don't pause don't hesitate just come
now i shall give you one minute exactly
for those who still need to move then
i'll pray
the sixty seconds begin now come
pray in your hearts that god will soften
hearts
just slip out and come
45 seconds left
god bless you
and i mean that god bless you
i prayed for my heart 30 seconds left
15 seconds
slip out and come
god bless you sister
we have five seconds left
then i pray
every head bowed every i close
reverently in the presence of the living
god
father in heaven
i have made the call
i believe you've given me the words
the spirit has touched hearts and your
people have come and i thank you for
them and i know you're happy to receive
them father they have come to say we
have come to say we have not given
ourselves to you 100
father we want to be sure that there is
no cause for you to destroy us as you
had no cause of destroy job or abraham
or lord or noah or abel
and now in the name of jesus christ
father i will speak to those who came
directly
give me again the right words help them
to understand
those of you who came look at me
i want you to give me permission to pray
for you
so that when i speak god hears all of
your voices if you give me that
spiritual right raise your right hand
there cannot be any exceptions if you
came you want me to pray you raise your
right hand give me the right to
represent you before the throne of god
every hand down
father
the voice you're hearing is the voice of
dozens
we have come to say
we are sorry
we have played the fool
we are sorry our commitment to you has
been partial yes lord we have been
decent we have been well mannered we
have been well trained we have been
cultured we have not stolen our
neighbor's house but we have not been
yours a hundred percent father we
apologize from our hearts
and we ask you to forgive us
please forgive us
and now god in the name of jesus we ask
you give us the righteousness of your
son
we count as dung all our earthly
possessions all our academic distinction
all that the world holds as glorious we
count it like paul as done now
and we ask you in jesus name
to give us your righteousness give us
the life of christ that all that pleases
us may be that which pleases you
hear us god and do it for the sake of
jesus we pray and we thank you in jesus
name let all god's people say amen honey
man and father for those standing back
there bless them we thank you for their
100 commitment and if there is someone
who should have come
and did not come give that person no
rest and father i mean that
do what you have to do
if it means making the person sick
breaking a leg firing the person lord i
don't care the person's salvation is
what counts
do what's necessary to break down that
opposition that you may save those for
whom jesus died
i pray
i pray in jesus name and for his sake
let god's people say with me amen
and amen god bless you let the words
remain on your hearts
and in all that we do
let us do it
with the consciousness that we are the
children of god righteous because he
made us so
and he has no cause to destroy us
i love god if you love god can you say
amen
god bless you
i love you i will see you tomorrow
remember today's work
we ought to keep it how
god bless you